[Music]
vying to retain relevance in the hotly
contested realm of battle royale games
player unknowns battlegrounds is about
to offer you a chance to play for free
you know if you have the time to take
out from that other battle royale game
that was already free during Xbox Live
Gold's free play days which begin on
April 19 and end on April 22 you'll be
able to play pub g4 none of your money's
you know apart from having your Xbox
Live Gold subscription during these free
days you'll be able to download and play
the full xbox game preview version of
the game including all multiplayer modes
should you decide this is the Battle
Royale game for you all battle points
earned during the free weekend will
carry over to the game proper this
announcement comes alongside the reveal
of new DLC for pub G which includes
exclusive clothes as you can see here
and will only be available for a month
beginning April 19th the pub g5 pack
will run you $7 stay tuned to game spot
for all the latest
[Music]
[Applause]
you